good evening everyone here and out there
on the Internet my name is Franz von
hull Towson I lead the design team here
at Tesla and I'm excited to welcome you
to the Tesla design studio here in
Hawthorne California we are here tonight
to talk about model 3 but we wouldn't be
here without years of intense Drive and
passion from the Tesla team and
leadership on an unwavering mission
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of all of
my colleagues here at Tesla it is my
honor to welcome to the stage mr. Elon
Musk
all right all right well well welcome
everyone welcome everyone to the model 3
unveil we are we have an amazing product
to show you tonight I think you're gonna
be blown away and but I want to start
talking it just just preface this by
talking about why why are we doing this
why is Tesla
why does has exist why why are we making
electric cars why does it matter
it's because it's very important to
accelerate the transition to sustainable
transport it really really really is
this is this is really important for the
future of the world we have record high
co2 levels we recently passed over for
403 parts per million of co2 in the
atmosphere you can see the chart and it
looks like a vertical line and it's
still climbing and the last time it
there was this level of carbon
concentration was 11 million years ago
okay that was approximately when
primates started walking upright the
world was very different we do not want
to return to that situation and and what
that's here to increase results in is a
steadily increasing temperature so we've
already increased by two degrees in fact
that doesn't tell the whole story
because the extremes of temperature
increased by as much as 20 degrees and
that line is going to keep going for
some time it's the future it's really
important it makes a difference if we
accelerate the transition to sustainable
transport and beyond the globe beyond
global warming there's just the fact
that combustion cars emit toxic gases
and according to an MIT study there are
53 thousand deaths per year in the US
alone from auto emissions so it stands
to reason that if if a vehicle is
spewing toxic gas that's obviously bad
for your health and so to address this
what we came up with the test
was what we called the secret master
plan so so this is the the first blog
that I ever wrote for the company and it
was originally a three step it's
originally a trilogy now it's a
four-part trilogy so it turns out but it
needed to we needed to figure out how
could we as a as a tiny company with
very few resources actually make a
difference and the only way to do this
was to start small to start with a low
volume car which is why we started with
the the Tesla Roadster so with any new
technology it takes multiple iterations
before you enter multiple iterations and
it takes economies of scale before you
can make it make it great and affordable
so step one was was the Roadster
the Roadster was high price and and low
volume but what really made a difference
was that it showed people that you could
show the world that you could make a
compelling electric car you could make a
great electric car but what was what was
unique about the Roadster was it was the
first really great electric car and
before the roads so people thought an
electric car would be would be slow and
ugly and low range and have bad
performance and we had to break that
mold it was incredibly important to show
that that wasn't true and so we made the
roaster which is fast it's beautiful
it's great great performance those of
you who bought the roaster thank you
so it was been and we only made 500
units year because that's all we really
could make forth for the Roadster but it
had a very leveraged effect in fact Bob
let's the Vice former vice chairman of
GM actually credits the Roadster with
the Chevy Volt program which led then
led to the Nissan Leaf program and
really even though we were making very
few cars it actually had a quite a huge
leverage effect on the auto industry but
there was still a lot more to do and a
lot of people said well the roads is
nice but it's sort of a toy and it's
very expensive and you couldn't really
make a car that people would use every
day or a car that could really compete
against the great combustion sedans of
the world so with it okay we're gonna
make the Model S so
so okay so for the Model S um any of you
uh drive Model S thank you so then you
know it's it's it's a great it's a great
sedan it hat it can seat up to seven
people five adults and two kids it's
tested by Road and track and Motor Trend
and others as the the fastest four-door
car in history ever and it's got great
handling it's got great technology it's
got so things like autopilot and and it
really it was rated by by almost every
group as as the as the best car in its
year and by Consumer Reports as the best
car ever yeah
again it was it was super the reason for
that is it's not just it to to achieve
some superlative in cars but to to show
what an electric car can do because
nobody believed that an electric car
could do this so what was really
important was to show the reason it was
important is not not to achieve you know
awards or anything like that it was to
just show the car industry show the
world that an electric car really can be
the best car that's what really really
mattered and now for for cars about half
the market wants a sedan about half the
market wants an SUV so we thought well I
will extend the the Model S platform
into the more legs
okay the both of these are very
important because the revenue from the
Model S and the X is what's needed to
develop the model 3 so the model 3 with
very high volume and and all the
engineering needed to achieve but the
cost reductions and the capabilities
that cost billions of dollars so the s
and the X are what pay for that Model 3
development so as what I say for all of
you who bought an S or an X thank you
for helping pay for the Model 3 so the
model 3 is happening because because of
you and so we actually have an S and an
X on the side there and has of course
the Falcon wig doors which did cause us
some challenges but now LM working so
now then going from the the s and the X
we finally come to we come to step 3
will deflect the final step in the in
the master plan which is a mass-market
affordable affordable car it was only
possible to do that after going through
the prior steps but we're here and we're
here to show that to you tonight so okay
so I'm gonna I'm gonna describe some of
the aspects of the model 3 and then
we'll end then and we'll yeah so let's
move to describe me look so show the
master plan again okay so that's the
mass plan with with steps 2 & 2.5 and
and now going to to to the model 3 first
of all I wanna start off by saying the
model 3 is gonna be an incredibly safe
car we really believe at Tesla that
safety has to come first we care about
you we want you to be safe we want your
friends and family to be safe this is
paramount the model 3 will be not just
be 5 star an average 3 5 star in every
category
and even the base model of even the base
model 3 will do 0 to 60 miles an hour or
0 to 100 killing us an hour in less than
6 seconds at Tesla we don't we don't
make slow cars and of course there will
be versions of the model 3 that go much
faster and in terms of range the range
will be at least an EPA rating of 250
miles I want to emphasize these are
minimum numbers we we hope to exceed
them
it will also all model 3s will come
standard with autopilot hardware and
although autopilot safety features will
be present in every car that you don't
you won't need to buy an option the
autopilot safety features will always be
there so then what the model 3 also fits
5 adults comfortably now that
comfortably is the important part here
ok um but the challenge obviously with
building a smaller car is how do you how
do you still make it comfortable with a
bunch of people inside so there are two
important design steps we did with the
model 3 to achieve that one was to move
the instant panel with the firewall
there really isn't a firewall if you
don't have a big combustion engine in
front we will remove the front seats
forward and compress the the instant
panel when you when you do your rides
tonight you'll see what I mean that
you're sitting a little further forward
it actually feels great on the front
seats that's what gitch gives you the
legroom to have 5 adults and so that
you're the first and second row had
plenty of legroom then on under the rear
roof area is actually one continuous
pane of glass and that the reason that
that's great is it because it gives you
amazing Headroom and a feeling of
openness so it has I think
by father it the best feeling best
roominess of any car in the size then
been in addition it has just just like
the Model S it has a front and rear
trunks so you can it has more cargo
capacity than any a gasoline car of the
same external dimensions and yeah and
you can actually if somebody asked you
this question recently is can you fit a
7-foot long surfboard on the inside the
answer is yes you can then with respect
to super charging all model threes will
come with super charging standard so the
reason super charging is very important
as as many of you know is that it gives
you freedom of travel okay it means you
can conveniently go where you want where
you want how you want and a lot about
having a car is it's about freedom it's
about Duke going where you want to go
and and so the super chargers are
critical to that so we're now at the
point where we've built out over 3600
superchargers worldwide and about the
same number about the same number of
destination charges that's present day
by the end of next year we will double
the number of superchargers
and and quadruple the number of
destination charges so you will be able
to go virtually anywhere and in fact
because the on-board charged with model
s is able to adapt to any country's
voltage and amperage wherever you go in
the world if there's electricity you can
charge so so then what about buying and
servicing so where we are today with
Tesla's we've got 215 locations in Asia
North America and Europe and by the end
of next year we expect to more than
double that to 441 locations so but the
key point being it nope almost no matter
where you are in North America Europe
and Eurasia you'll if you're in it near
any even midsize metro area you'll be
able to buy a car and get your car
serviced so now how are we gonna make
these cars okay good good question
we need to achieve high volume
production so this isn't this is in two
parts first there is the vehicle factory
so the our Fremont factory in the past
has actually made almost 500,000 cars a
year so we're confident that we can that
Tesla can achieve that number in the
future in terms of vehicle production so
I think that's that's going to be once a
straightforward but very doable and and
then what about what about batteries
because in order to produce half a
million cars a year we would actually
need this the same battery production
we're basically to absorb the entire
world's lithium ion production that
that's why we are building the
gigafactory these are the recent
pictures of the of the gigafactory
this is a vital element
so to give you a sense of scale the
gigafactory will actually have the
largest footprint of any building of any
kind okay volumetrically it will only be
second to the Boeing factory in
Washington so that this is really quite
an enormous facility it in fact it'll
produce more lithium-ion batteries then
all other factories in the world
combined there's one location so we're
talking about 50 50 gigawatt hours a
year of production and it won't just be
at that volume would also be producing
the most advanced cell and battery in
the world so it's the combination of
high volume with the most advanced
technology is what enables us to make
the model 3 and we already it's already
operational today so when when our
deliveries well they're next year so
so I do feel fairly confident that it
will be next year yeah and and then in
terms of price
well of course it'll be $35,000 and I
want to emphasize I went emphasized that
the but even if you buy no options at
all this will still be an amazing car
you will not be able to buy a better car
for $35,000 or even close even if you if
you get no options so it's a really good
car even with no options so do you want
to see the car
well oh we don't have it for you tonight
I'm just kidding pause it's April Fool
somewhere all right let's bring them out
all right for today
you like the car
all right and this is this is kind of
crazy but I just learnt just told that
the total number of orders for the Model
3 in the past 24 hours has now passed
115,000
so so this said hey thank you that's a
lie yeah
so they thank you to everyone that that
ordered the car we love you and for
those those that for those of you that
are here please enjoy your rides tonight
in the model three and put for those
online you can order at Tesla comm thank
you
you